[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID MCCLUSKY: One of
the most familiar features
of Google Maps is autocomplete.
Google's type ahead
functionality.
Autocomplete reduces
errors in entries
and provides a better
experience for the user.
This functionality is included
in our Google Places API
library.
However, many developers
tend to overlook it
when building their own
mapping applications.
Including autocomplete
in your application
is as easy as these three steps.
Step one, be sure to include
the Places library when
loading the JavaScript API.
Step two, create a text
box and instantiate
the autocomplete service.
Step three, create an event
to capture the results.
You can also further
customize the experience
by biasing the results to a
particular geographic area
or by filtering out the
types of results displayed.
To get started, take
a look at our blog
and read the developer
documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]